foreign
get started I want to welcome everyone
to the demise research conference and
we're going to be presenting today an
integrated approach to breast cancer
risk assessment using mammal screen and
epic and primary care and you're going
to hear from our panel of investigators
on this project
next slide
[Music]
this work is funded by an arc ro1 and we
have no relevant Financial relationships
with commercial interests to disclose
next slide
as you can see we are a
multi-disciplinary team that includes
clinicians informaticians epic for
research members an expert in UC from
UCLA on breast cancer risk assessment a
genetic counselor and importantly we
have five patient advisors between the
ages of 40 and 74.
next slide
I thought I would begin with just a
little tiny overview of what a patient
decision Aid is because mammal screen
includes not only a risk assessment but
also a decision Aid and these are tools
that help patients become involved in
decision making by providing information
about options and outcomes and helping
patients clarify their values around
those but they are designed to promote
conversation with a health practitioner
not to replace a health care
practitioner
next slide
position AIDS help with shared decision
making by providing information on
options importantly establishing a
Common Language so the clinician doesn't
spend 15 minutes just going over the
terminology and that sort of thing it's
also a way to give patients a safe
environment to set priorities for the
decision and it provides a structured
guidance for shared discussion
next slide
so there's been a there's been a
Cochrane review that's been conducted
probably over the last 15 to 20 years
and the most recent review in 2017
105 rcts revealed that patients using
decision AIDS when compared to usual
care reported greater knowledge felt
more informed felt more clear about
their priorities for the decision
also fewer people were passive in
decision-making and fewer remained
undecided next slide
and if you're interested in whether
there is a decision Aid on a topic that
you want to explore there's an inventory
of decision AIDS that's kept by the
Ottawa Hospital research group so you
can go to this site and look to see if
your topic is already in a decision Aid
that you might want to consider reaching
out to the Developers
okay next slide
so mammal screen was developed using the
international
standards sorry just a second
barking my barking dog here and the goal
of the if does collaboration is to
establish an internationally approved
set of criteria to determine the quality
of patient decision AIDS and Lindsay
appeals just start flipping through the
well there's four is there enough detail
to help you make a decision is it
unbiased and understandable next one
does it help you clarify your values and
finally
these are structured guidance for the
conversation later let's go on to the
next slide
so the man screen tool was developed in
partnership with patients and Primary
Care clinicians and it was designed to
support the USPS TF breast cancer
screening and prevention recommendations
to identify patients who might benefit
from genetic counseling
to educate average risk patients about
breast cancer screening and current
recommendations
and to to facilitate that shared
discussion and finally and this is what
we're really focusing on in this new
work improve accuracy and completeness
of patient medical and family history
related to breast cancer risk in Epic
next slide
just a quick overview we started this
work in 2012 with women 40 to 49
we then expanded the tool to address the
needs of women 40 to 74 and you might be
wondering why do we need a tool a
decision tool for 50 to 74 when it's
when screening is recommended but but
what this tool helps the patient and
clinician know is whether the person
should come every year or maybe every
two years
in 2020 we received an r01 to begin
integrating mammal screen with Epic
and we actually launched recruitment
with this new tool integrated tool in
2022 in
um internal OHSU Internal Medicine
Clinic
okay next slide
just to give you an idea of what kinds
of questions the patients answer around
breast cancer these come from a
validated tool and I ask questions about
personal history and family history and
just even since this this tool has been
created we've now also added an unsure
category that's not shown here in this
slide but if a patient doesn't know for
example about brca family you know
family members have it they can check
Venture okay next slide
the patient gets a report in this
particular instance after answering the
questions the patient learns I mean this
particular patient has a previous
history of breast ovarian cancer so the
actual decision Aid isn't appropriate
for this person but it does help them
understand any next steps what we also
found out is that for women at increased
risk mammal screen helped identify an
additional 10 of patients
and there was also discrepancy between
the risk information in mammal screen
and epic alone some of that just being
the currency of the information the
patient may have had a new family member
who was diagnosed with breast cancer and
it's just simply not in Epic yet next
slide
so for the patients who are average risk
they go on to use the decision Aid and
this is a graphic that we created that
helps women understand that some breast
cancer grows very aggressively some
grows quite slowly and as you can see
we've used Graphics we write things in
plain language we test this with our
patient advisors and we often have a
have quite a bit of pilot testing with
clinicians and patients before we roll
out of decision Aid let's go to the next
slide
in this graphic we're trying to help the
patient understand the yield of
screening but we don't use terms like
yield of screening and we customize this
particular graphic based on the age of
the woman so if so if I was in my 40s I
wish I was but I'm not if a thousand
women in their 40s had a mammogram today
125 would receive that dreaded phone
call that more tests are needed two
cancers would be found and two
pre-cancers would be found but 121 would
not have cancer and if you click the
button there Lindsay it'll highlight
that
if for the normal results 874 of the 875
would have would be told they had normal
results but there would actually be one
cancer missed
let's go to the next slide
so then we have them set some priorities
and you can imagine that we initially
had quite a long list of benefits and
quite a long list of harms but through
work with patients and clinicians we
narrowed that list down so we asked them
to pick the one benefit that was is
important to them in this case it's
peace of mind having a mammogram that
shows no cancer versus catching cancer
early
we also asked them to identify the harm
they most want to avoid in this case
we're showing extra tests and worry and
no improvement or length of Life notice
we don't use terms like over diagnosis
or false positive because those are
those are very difficult terms for our
audience to understand and then we ask
them to pick the one benefit or harm
that's most important
let's go to the next slide
so in 2020 we published the most recent
data collection that we did at the
internal medicine clinic and we
collected data on feasibility uptake and
clinical some clinical data let's go to
the next slide
so what we found is it was feasible to
integrate mammal screen into the
practices
in terms of uptake we sent messages out
by my chart 76 of the patients opened
their chart and 37 percent of those
patients used mammal screens so they
clicked the link within to get to mammal
screen most people spent about six
minutes
using mammal screen and the clinical
team reported positive experiences and
what we found is that it provided more
timely and complete breast cancer risk
information than was currently stored in
Epic
go to the next slide but we also learned
there were some challenges in order to
put information back into epic we had to
manually put this information back in
and that it could be error prone it was
labor intensive
also the system required us to send
manual my chart messages that had
embedded in them and encrypted the MRN
so that we could match the mammal screen
report back to the correct patient
and then finally the patients had to
answer questions that might already be
in the medical chart so with all of this
in mind we designed our new study go to
the next slide
and that is to integrate map the mammo
screen tool with Epic
to evaluate clinician use of mammal
screen and to evaluate the patient
uptake of mail screen
and next slide and with that I will hand
off to Dr Nelson to speak about breast
cancer screening and prevention clinical
recommendations and risk assessment
thank you so much good afternoon or
morning we're kind of on the cusp of
that I'm going to spend the next few
minutes describing the breast cancer
screening and prevention clinical
recommendations and risk assessment
that is embedded in Mammoth screen as Dr
Eden indicated
the initial motivation for developing a
tool was to help clinicians navigate the
sometimes confusing and conflicting
recommendations regarding three breast
cancer screening and prevention
recommendations for Primary Care these
include mammography screening for
average risk women there's some loaded
words in here we're going to go through
here in a minute the second one on risk
assessment for genetic counseling and
genetic testing for brca12 related
cancer so these are
a subset of women who have genetic
predisposition for cancer
uh and then they use some medications to
reduce the risk of breast cancer so I'll
just highlight that these
recommendations have all been endorsed
by um uh groups uh that are including
hersa the women's preventive service
initiative which I've been working with
um for many years and the years of
Services Task Force which we've also
been worked working with for several
years have established and accepted
these guidelines as a standard of care
and covered under the preventive service
mandates of the Affordable Care Act so
they are provided without copay or
deductive charges so these are supposed
to happen
um so go to the next slide
uh I'm not going to go through all of
this but clinicians in the room or
anyone who's been eligible for these
types of recommendations will appreciate
how messy this gets the deeper we go who
is average risk that is a million dollar
question we're trying to to help
determine through an easy tool that's
why it's taken us so many years and a
lot of effort average risk women are the
target population for mammography
screening for the recommendations that I
just mentioned but also for the
mamascreen tool
um so there are the recommendations that
are covered under the ACA come from
hersa through the iom and the wpsi we
worked on these for many years but all
women can initiate mammography screening
no earlier than age 40 we're talking
about routine average risk women
um and no later than 50.
um screen every two years and as
frequently as every year based on
clinical considerations continue through
at least age 74 but age alone should not
be the basis to discontinue screening
and a shared decision-making process
involving the woman in her healthcare
clinician should be used for decisions
about when to initiate screening how
often to screen and when to stop so
that's quite a few things to go through
the U.S preventive Services Task Force
issued
um c b and I recommendations some of you
may be familiar with meaning you know
individualized screening
for a c everyone should be screened for
a b and no evidence for an eye so this
gets a little dicey if we had another
hour to talk about this we would have uh
another other organizations have
different screening recommendations so
this is rather messy uh if you go to the
next slide uh the other recommendations
involve the um breast cancer risk
assessment for genetic mutations so the
recommendation is to screen all women
with a risk assessment tool to identify
patients with family histories
associated with these mutations and
those that screen positive with a tool
or a set of questions or some kind of
instrument then would receive genetic
counseling which is a whole other
encounter involving at least an hour in
software and kindreds and it's it's a
whole another referral if indicated
after that then they would undergo
internet testing
the third recommendation involves
identifying who's at increased for
breast cancer and who might benefit from
medications that actually reduce the
risk of breast cancer by 50 percent
tamoxifen relax for aromatase Inhibitors
so again here we're talking about risks
versus assessments shared decision
making when is that going to happen
um so let's take on the next slide
um the first question who's an increased
risk for breast cancer so um let's take
a look what would help us sort that out
well we unfortunately found after
reviewing
um the predicted performance of 18 risk
assess instruments involved uh in 25
studies with over 5 million women
enrolled including the so-called uh
popular Gale model that they aren't
helpful they are not accurate in
estimating risk their discriminatory
accuracy range from 0.55 to 0.65 for
those of you in that field that is
slightly better than coin toss as to who
actually will get breast cancer
so that's not too helpful so what are we
going to do we've gotten a lot of
pressure to implement the Gale model or
other models into Mammoth screen what
we've been pushing back if we go to the
next slide we'll see what's in um
the Gale model listed in the First
Column age age at menarchy a bunch of
other things all the other permutations
of of the models
that kind of grow from there there are
all kinds of other things added in
reality they don't all the more you have
more factors in there it doesn't perform
better the most dominant factor in all
these models is age
so we took a different approach with
Mammoth green very intentionally if we
go to the next slide
uh Mammoth screen identifies individual
factors that we call red flags these are
clearly high risk factors so um if those
of you have done the demo you know the
first few questions are about do you
have a symptom now do you have a breast
symptom lump discharge skin change we
want to sort that out before you go too
far into this have you had a radiation
exposure at a high level before age 30.
that's a very small slice of the
population maybe someone who had Hodgkin
lymphoma treatment that increases your
risk that's a red flag do you have a
mutation or a family member we need to
sort that out have you had previous
cancer breast ovarian particularly that
could be a problem then we move on to
the breast biopsy question there have
been a lot of people that biopsies most
of those aren't sure no cancer but a
chunk of those show a high risk lesion
they're in a different category they
need to be followed more closely and
sadly a lot of people don't know what
their biopsy was so we need to sort that
out
um and we can't really label them as
average risks we sort out who's at high
risk so this is the first part of
Mammoth screen it it helps sort out
these kinds of risk factors and who
might go on to other things before even
considering routine mammography
to go to the next slide we go well who
is eligible for genetic counseling
remember we're trying to help sort
through that so that clinicians can
satisfy that practice recommendation to
refer on the individuals who may need
counseling
um
it's not a large population that has
these mutations but it's enough
um
to seven percent of women with breast
cancer and 10 to 15 percent of women
with ovarian cancer are carriers of
inherited pathogenic mutations they pass
these on through relatives and they may
um appear kind of out of the blue for
some families some families have sadly a
fairly trackable record of cancer but
it's important to know who's carrier and
they have things they can do
um to reduce their risk including some
pretty drastic things like mastectomies
um but they should know their risks so
um a carrier of either of these
mutations has an increased risk for
cancer it doesn't mean they're going to
get cancer so we consider them risk
factors not um not a 100 percent risk
carrier that it's going to happen
so we need to sort that out so if we go
to the next slide we see that we looked
at all the tools that you use to triage
women to see who's has a mutation and
actually these are accurate they have
very precise questions about family
histories that are quite linked to
um some kind of genetic tendency we
looked at eight risk instruments and 14
studies with large number of women in
the performance characteristics were
more uh in the clinical feasibility
range and so we thought those were
helpful so if we go to the next slide we
opted to we reviewed all these from ammo
screen and selected one that was
developed by the CDC and validated in
large populations of American women so
hopefully reflecting as best we can that
population
and as you can see this is so simple it
can be done as a paper pencil test in a
low-tech environment but mammal screen
and others are implementing these more
in electronic
um systems but based on a series of
simple questions
um the person gets points if you have
two points or more or you need a
referralogenetic counseling where they
can actually spend a lot of time getting
more precise information and actually
create risks estimates that are going to
be useful in decision making so this is
a triage this is not a definitive family
history assessment
uh but it's what the task force is
asking people to do uh based on the
science that this is helpful uh if we go
to the next slide
see how this fits in okay we got through
those first risk questions I remember
the biopsy and all those other things
now we move on as you may have seen from
The Tool uh a point is gained for anyone
with Ashkenazi Jewish Heritage since
there is a cluster of genes uh mutations
that can increase risk for cancer so
that's an important population in this
U.S population that we need to keep an
eye on and evaluate we look at Family
histories uh and unfortunately the the
mutations can fly under the radar for a
while so you may not know
um but generally it expresses itself
that an expressed Gene is an important
Gene um it's important to know histories
and um we asked a series of questions
that Dr Eden showed a few of them a
little more up close earlier so once
they get through this we have a better
idea who may be at higher risk we can go
to the next slide that's I think my last
one so now we go back to our first
question who's the average risk well
it's a process of elimination in the
mammoth screen Tool uh and probably we
thought the best way to really sort this
out average risk is not having
characteristics associated with high
risk that was previous diagnosis of
ovarian cancer high-risk breast lesion
clinical signs or symptoms of breast
cancer carriers of those mutations or
other familial syndromes or other
syndromes besides brca those will be
picked up probably in the system to and
once they get to genetic counseling they
can really sketch out those family
histories and then that high dose
radiation
so we now know who could move on to the
um
mammography screening piece of the
manuscript tool and hopefully these
individuals will get their high risks
addressed
um so I'll stop there I think that's the
less I don't have
all right excuse me hi Katie benching
can you hear me
can you guys hear me
yes no
yes we can okay great hi so um my name
is Katie benching I'm a primary care
clinician
um doc uh it's a pleasant educator
um a generalist
um by training and uh continuing but
also with a focus on women's health
within the primary care environment from
um when I started my career so this is a
copy of some of our team who happen to
be in the clinic during the the pandemic
um and the front desk of our Clinic I am
going to talk about the clinical
workflow related to mamascreen and
um
and some of the details there
um I want to I do want to thank
um some individuals on our Clinic team
as well as the whole group um so in the
pilot study we had I had two partners Dr
Haney and Hassan who helped with a pilot
and we've had Abby chesmet who's on this
call as a panel coordinator with medical
assistant training who's been our
um key on the ground person
and as we've moved toward the r01
eventually they'll be about 75 faculty
and residents involved in the study as
well as
um about eight nurses helping us next
slide
um so this is the mammoth screen
workflow this is specific to our clinic
and epic
um Mammoth green
is
um adaptable to any essentially any EMR
or clinic workflow
um and we are tracking the decisions and
issues that have come up about the
clinical workflow to help others who may
be implementing in different settings
think through things but that could this
could have been this can be adapted very
differently in different settings
um I want to note that there are six
steps
um and that there are five steps before
even anything comes to the clinician so
the whole one of our goals was to make
sure this was really really high yield
and low burden to the the very busy
Primary Care docs on the ground
uh next slide
um the first step is a my chart
invitation to the patient now
um and we've uh actually reworded this
at this
um invitation several times to increase
our yield of uh responses
um
you all probably already know this but
it is very common for uh research
studies to to use my chart invitations
as a as their primary one of their
primary sources for recruitment
um it is asynchronous and therefore
convenient for patients um some patients
will open
um Mammoth screen and um
come back to it after they've been able
to talk to relatives so we think we're
getting better information by doing it
this way and it doesn't take up the
precious time of a visit
but of course anyone who doesn't have
have my chart would not have access to
this and uh folks who don't who aren't
as digitally literate or not as facile
with using my chart or even
um
other digital applications might not be
have access to it
uh next slide
um so risk assessments The Next Step I
think that obviously Heidi went through
this we're in a wonderful detail and
explained the reasoning and and the
process
um and but essentially we'll find out
but the the unique part to this study is
that in this application amount of
screen is that we can pull information
to and from epic and Mammoth screen to
coordinate the information so the
patient actually reconciles health
history that's already in Epic and
doesn't have to repeat it and
um
and we can make sure that um
and if there's inaccurate information in
effect the patient can outline that
next
um
this is the patient report so a patient
receives a personalized report this the
information here matches in
um content what's sent in the clinician
report
um and is saved to the patient records
in a plain text version as well
um
let's see uh
this allows us as we as as Karen said us
to not have to do manual entry into epic
and avoid errors it allows us to
um do some
uh standardized automatic workflow of
um the outcomes of the uh of the
of the reported issues so for example
um if symptoms are reported
um we can automatically send to the
nurse
um if the patient is not average risk it
can go to our panel coordinator we'll go
through that
um and we in in in developing this we
tried we used our Clinic workflow our
standard clinical workflow for each um
action as much as possible next slide
this is the uh clinician
um summary
um it's automatically saved to this
chart it's easy to find VIA just a
simple
um
uh search in um in Epic
there's a report that is sent
um to the triage nurse only if they're
symptoms
um and
the uh
we are we develop this with input from
our clinicians over serial
um serial discussions to make it most
useful for them to be able to find what
they need easily
and again it matches what is in the
clinician record
next slide
um so this has this is um
a care coordinator note so Abby chismet
is our phenomenal care coordinator and
um she receives these reports and
creates a note when when appropriate so
and I'm and
um this again has been
um iterated with Abby making changes and
the clinicians giving input
um so uh this is automated so can you
just start the automation
um Lindsay
think
so the care coordinator next
um
it'll have the date where the data came
in so it's clear when the patient filled
out the mamascreen next
um
it'd be if patient has
um new or changed information that's
highlighted at the top in red so it's
easy to find next
um
so so you can easily see oh boy does
this patient have a patient does this
patient have an appointment coming up I
just need to remind myself to talk to
him about it versus oh I need to take
some action to have the patient schedule
an appointment next
um dates and locations of the mammograms
and breast biopsies
that are able to be found and pulled in
and those are the ones in Epic and Care
everywhere are pulled in for ease next
and there this is the full clinician
summary report next slide
um and then
we outline
um various actions that can be taken
based upon
um the patient's risk in their reports
um so for example if someone's average
risk without any new information that
the um no message goes to the primary
care doc everything is filed and the
summary is expected to be potentially
reviewed at the next patient visit to
facilitate shared decision making if
that needs to be done
um versus if someone has new symptoms
the message is sent to our tree as
nurses as with any whether someone
called in or sent a my chart message
saying they have a breast symptom would
be treated the same way
um the and then the nurse takes care of
that before it comes to a clinician
the um
the three middle uh situations
are where the care coordinator would
send a message
um
with the information and the primary the
clinical Primary Care doc would need to
make some decision about what to do for
example if they thought they had a
significant family history that they
screened positive for risk for brca or
uh brca they could they would could
probably have them come in to discuss a
referral to genetic counseling
uh next slide
um
the uh the other the other thing that
can it happens automatically is a um
problem list entry to reconcile is
posted in Epic and it's called at above
average risk for breast cancer and
um this can't be automatically put in it
has to be reconciled by a provider in
Epic but if you if you but it's very
simple to do so if you see it you can
just click that problem list entry and
it will automatically pull in the Miami
screen report so it's easy to find
next slide
and um this is a little bit another way
of looking at our notification process
um
if a patient has no breast symptoms
then the follow the the nurses are not
all involved only our care coordinator
um but if there are breast symptoms the
triage nurse is also involved
um and uh if the patient is average risk
no automatic notification happens
um and so the idea is only to send to
the clinician what they need to see with
as much information as possible from the
team
um and the background of Mammoth screen
before that before it gets to them next
slide
um so we have lots of Lessons Learned
um obviously my chart invitations
um to participate are successful but
will not lead to engage with all
patients and we've been working hard on
that
um
we've had input from stakeholders that
has been invaluable and continues to be
even since we've um every time we redo
this presentation there's something else
to add
um the patients requested the option of
unsure
um
the clinicians requested risk-based
cancer screening and prevention
recommendations which I'll show you next
the genetic counselors requested that
patients being referred to consultations
be noted that they're going to look at
their genetic risk not just for brca but
other things
the nurses requested that we
um clarify that whether breast symptoms
were New or Old or whether they're
evaluated or not
um we are customizing
um the patient invite to include the PCP
name
and clinicians request a virus a variety
of training materials including a short
demo video for reference
next slide
where you're going to show the video
Lindsay
I can go ahead and show the video okay
um so this is uh from the training board
for the clinicians
um it just kind of briefly goes through
the how a clinician might process a
mamascreen report
one of the requests that the clinicians
have made is that it needed to be you
know two to three minutes long so I
actually used an AI voice generator
called 11 labs
for it to
create a clone of my voice and then I
typed out a script so it um really
streamlined uh streamlined the work so
I'll go ahead and play now
Maybe
hello my name is Lindsay Watson I'm the
project manager for the mammo screen
study at OHSU in this short
demonstration video I'll walk through an
example of how mammo screen fits into
the pcp's overall workflow you can find
more information about mammo screen in
the IMC Wiki on teams under epic tips or
feel free to reach out to me over email
at watsonlin ohsu.edu or send Dr
benching a message on teams in basket or
outlook for this demo I'll walk through
an example case in the Epic test
environment using fake patient data
we'll start at the point in the clinic
workflow where the PCP receives a
notification from Abby chesimet the
study care coordinator who has reviewed
the patients chart for additional
pertinent information such as date of
last mammogram and highlights the new
patient reported information before
routing to the patient's PCP as a
patient call
underneath the care coordinator node is
the clinician summary with more detailed
information about the patient's risk
factors and responses to screening
questions at the end of the clinician
summary you will find risk-based
clinical follow-up suggestions that
include current uspstf guidelines
this information will be updated as new
evidence and recommendations come in
the patient is overdue for a mammogram
and does not have a future appointment
scheduled with Dr benching in this case
Dr benching decides to order a mammogram
and sends a request to Abby to ask the
patient to schedule an appointment and
provide information about how they can
schedule a mammogram
she then makes a sticky note as a
reminder for the next patient visit Dr
benching can also choose to add
increased risk of breast cancer to the
patient's problem list by clicking the
outside records reconciliation option
this is automatically added by mammo
screen for patients at increased risk
but it is up to the clinician to add it
to the problem list
once the diagnosis is added future
clinicians can hover over the diagnosis
to see the clinician summary in the
overview section at the patient visit Dr
benching can verify the family history
with the patient update the mammography
health maintenance modifier and
determine if a referral for genetic
counseling is appropriate
this concludes the mammo stream demo
thank you so much for watching please
don't hesitate to reach out to me Dr
benching or Karen Eden with any
questions
and thank you for participating in our
study
thanks Lindsay
um
and Lindsay's AI voice
the other thing the clinicians requested
was a uh some very simple risk-based
clinical follow-up messaging and
um we ended up bucketing in into six
areas average risk
um younger age and older age average
risk due to family history risk scores
those folks of course would be
considered referral referrals for
counseling above average risk due to
other reasons which
um
and as an above average residue to known
brca one and two mutations versus
previously treated cancer
um part of one one of the one of the
clinical follow-up messaging issues is
for folks who are high rep women who are
high risk
um
should their survey their man their um
screening for for breast cancer change
and the answer is maybe and yes in some
cases
um and so that the next slide actually
goes into detail about the
um recommended action in these six
situations
um which
so for example
um if someone had a previously history
of breast or ovarian cancer we don't
actually give a clear
um specific answer because that's such a
large group with varied recommendations
but say surveillance should be
individualized versus the person who has
a family history risk we discuss uh
genetic counseling
as well as
recommendation for how to mitigate risk
next slide
and I think it's uh
Ben's turn
yes thank you Katie
um so I'm Ben Orwell I'm one uh I'm one
of the Pete's Critical Care faculty and
and also uh clinician informaticist
um here at d meist i uh I'm gonna talk a
little bit about our EHR integration and
some of the things that we've done and
some of the things that we've learned so
um to support all these assessments and
clinical workflows that you've heard
about so far we had to do a lot of work
to integrate member screen with the with
the EHR that we all know and love so
well
um so to do this we focused on
information and data exchange standard
called fire and many of you are probably
familiar with it but it's short for fast
Healthcare interoperability resources
and it's been in development for about a
decade but is still in active
development it takes Health Data and
packages it into resources which are
these discrete chunks of information
such as patients observations like Labs
or vitals medications and many other
data types that you might imagine
the format is really web friendly and
importantly computers use a standardized
application programming interface or API
and security mechanisms to interact with
each other using fire next slide
um so uh what makes fire special
um why would we like to use it well the
API is the key the fact that there's a
standard open and computable way to
interact with systems like ehrs makes a
lot of things possible and big tech
companies use these types of data
interfaces all the time to allow users
and companies to interact with their
data
but beyond that everyone is using fire
because the government is starting to
require it you've probably heard of the
cures act and information blocking buyer
aprs apis are a part of these
regulations and are part of upcoming
regulations around payment and coverage
information exchange among others it
helps that fire is open source and free
to use next slide
but perhaps the most important thing is
that fire aims to make Healthcare data
and applications interoperable and that
means that using fire we hope to be able
to build things that can be used across
multiple Health Systems with minimal
additional work Arc funded Us in part
based on the premise that we might be
able to make Mammoth screen something
that could be used all over
first though we tried to make it work at
OHSU next slide
and so here you can see each of the
actors in this little play and I'm going
to try to demonstrate how we leveraged
fire
next slide to help data flow back and
forth between them so first we invite
the patient to try out Mammoth screen
next through a mess through a message
from the EHR through their patient
portal sent via bolt Communications from
the ehr's population Health tools
the patient then launches the
application via oauth based smart launch
next slide this then allows the patient
data to flow into mamascreen from the
EHR sending identifying information
demographic data medical and family
history these help to pre-populate some
of the answers to the mammoth screen
risk assessment next Slide the patient
then completes the survey and Upon
finishing next Slide the report
resulting report as well as pertinent
conditions are given to the patient and
simultaneously written back into the
medical record via a smart back-end
service API call
next slide additionally we send several
messages back to the clinical team that
you've seen already via a proprietary
API and this was an unfortunate
departure from our fire only approach
that was a result of one of several
limitations that we ran into that I will
discuss but it was especially important
to allow notification of the triage
nurse pool like we've talked about and
if there were urgent new symptoms
requiring attention
the story is not over though
next slide so now that the data are in
the EHR the clinical team can review
them directly there
and but we also built the provider
facing smart launch that can be used by
providers to bring up details about the
patient's mammascreen survey displayed
within the application itself
next slide and the result of all of this
we hope is the standard workflow that
supports both individualized risk
assessment and shared decision making
next slide so we got a lot of what we
wanted we created a system that allowed
for bulk invitations population of
patient Health Data into the tool from
the EHR writing of results back to the
HR for record-keeping and clinician
visibility and all with the workflow
that involves minimal human touch and
could potentially scale much more easily
than our old system
next slide
however
next slide of course there were limit
issues there were real limitations in
the functionality even of The Limited
set of write-enabled fire resources that
our EHR supports
conditions written back to the EHR were
left in a state of limbo as demonstrated
until manually reconciled into the chart
by a clinician which may or may not
happen
document reference resources which are
the notes that we write back we're
limited to plain text even though our
EHR is heavily web enabled
another major limitation is that
encounters cannot currently be created
via fire every other piece of Pinnacle
data written into the system must have
an Associated encounter and this left us
forced to use a workflow that creates an
encounter when each patient is invited
to use the tool
it works but it currently limits our
ability to open up this tool on a
completely public invitation free basis
so as I mentioned there's currently no
Firebase method method of sending
messages in our EHR
and lastly we ran into a number of
interesting policy and governance
questions many of which are more General
in scope than just for our application
around how to handle data written into
the system by fire and how service level
fire application should be allowed or
not to interact with private or
sensitive patient accounts within the
system
but these things aside next next slide
I want to describe some of our early
results which are very encouraging and
we've got this application in production
and have done five pilot waves each with
25 to 70 patients
um we have had so far an impressive 36
response rate
with 93 of those who have accessed the
tool completing it
next slide and among those patients who
com did complete it 12 of reported
breast symptoms 38 percent have reported
information that was not seen when we
queried the EHR via fire
and another two percent reported
discordant information that is that the
data pulled from the EHR seem to be
incorrect in some way
next slide of course we fixed a few bugs
along the way as well what are pilots
for anyway
next slide so lastly here I want to
describe some of our upcoming plans
we're continuing to roll out to uh to
additional patients and hopefully we'll
be rolling out to even larger cohorts in
our stepped approach later on we have a
series of interviews and provide with
providers and patients that are working
to help us understand their experiences
with the tool and we'll also be
continuing to review charts to
understand how mammal screen Compares
with um manually extracted EHR data for
risk assessment and then eventually we
hope to make this tool more widely
available to other sites and
organizations next slide
so it's been a great pleasure presenting
to all of you and I want to thank of
course all of our team as well as Arc
and D mice and Mongoose projects such as
where our developers
has his company and we want to open up
next slide to any questions that the
audience may have
thank you
thanks Ben I will go ahead and ask a
question
um
uh your you know the comments on
experience with fire is is really
interesting and actually I think
important because
um as many of us know fire is being kind
of touted as the um uh do all for be all
and do all for interoperability
um so it it sounds like there were some
kind of technical shortcomings
um with fire maybe you could just
elaborate those a little bit more and
what might need to be
um fixed or improved and maybe not so
much in fire but maybe in how it's
implemented in Epic and then there's the
larger issue of the policy questions
which actually no technology will solve
um and and then maybe a second question
might be is how would you
um what would your recommendations be on
on sort of reconciling some of those
policy issues
yeah
um I think this is this great questions
um and
it's definitely a challenging situation
you know Medical Data are the Integrity
of those data are really important we
want to make sure that as we sort of be
are Innovative and are expanding the
ways in which the medical record systems
can interact with other systems like
mamascreen that we don't
um
that we don't compromise sort of the
functionality of the core systems that
we use to take care of patients so I
think it's reasonable that epic and
other organizations have been taking a
cautious approach and a stepwise
approach to implementing some of these
um these new standards and the and the
amount of integration that they are
allowing with fire I think that
um certainly the ability to read data
has been really improving rapidly over
time and epic has been a leader honestly
uh compared with other
ehrs as far as the support for different
types of medical data that they allow us
to extract via fire I think honestly
some of the technical challenges that we
run into are that we as providers and as
a system don't do that awesome of a job
putting data into discrete places within
the medical record a lot of what exists
in the medical record when it comes to
the types of information we're
interested in for risk assessments like
this is sort of prose or scattered
around we the clinicians in the audience
I'm sure know if you want to find the
pieces of data that that you need to
make a risk assessment for a patient you
might have to search through the chart
for 5 or 10 or 15 minutes to make sure
that you've seen it all you might have
to go to different organizations to find
all those pieces of data and so these
are limitations that we haven't been
able to fully overcome
I also think there's an element of the
the right back part of it that
um you know honestly epic hasn't been
required and no one else has been
required to support right back
technology
um via fire despite the fact that the
standard itself is is bi-directional
um and so I think
epic has uh has definitely Incorporated
some writing and will allow data to be
written in I think they're just um
they're taking it slow
and probably as we continue to Advocate
with regulatory bodies like the office
of the national coordinator and CMS and
other groups you know we may be able to
nudge that a little bit further so
I think
there's progress honestly every year
every six months we're seeing
improvements and expansion of the amount
of support that there are for some of
these things and our our governance
processes are really
I think struggling to keep up but to me
it's really all about well if I'm a
provider right and I want to write data
into this into the record system I need
to provide my credentials to
authenticate myself and to show that I
have the right to do that
fire allows you to do that just in the
same way that you do when you log into
epic and write notes and you know sign
orders you use you can use the same
credentials and the same login process
so I don't see those things as being
very different but still it's scary
um to see the little bit of control
outside your electronic record system
and so we're keeping work on that at
OHSU I think it's going to be it's going
to be a process I don't want to take up
too much time answering the question so
I'll stop there and we have a question
in chat and we also have um Nicole
weiskopf has got her hand up so I'll
start with a question in chat
oh it looks like Katie has already
responded
um
sorry I'm getting uh go ahead so
essentially
um the Collision report has the
information of the last mammogram as
well as the information needed to do to
consider whether they would follow usual
screening or
um or not
um so it doesn't give like an official
won't give an official Joe uh Joan Smith
needs a mammogram
July 30th next year but the information
to make that decision is there
collated in one place which doesn't
happen now
does that answer the question and then
Nicole you had a question
yeah
first I just wanted to say this is a
really fantastic project and
presentation and I really enjoyed all of
this
uh my question is less about the
technology and I guess more about
um decision Tools in general
how do you keep them up to date
um either as you know the treatments
change or our knowledge about
the cancer itself changes and how it
progresses how do you maintain the tools
so that is an excellent question we as
you saw Dr Nelson presented the evidence
um and that the whole tool is based on
evidence as the evidence changes we do
have to update the tool which brings in
a question of if you know that if a
grant paid for the creation of the tool
you know ultimately you need to maintain
the tool and so
um it at some point you'll have to
figure up a figure out a maintenance
strategy and that we are including some
maintenance kinds of questions with our
post interviews
because this is not it's not as easy as
you might guess they were so but we we
do have built-in a plan to work with
with Heidi about updating as evidence
changes
well thank you
it's like Stephen has a question maybe
could I just add one comment there to
that update we've already we've already
tweaked it over the years so we have the
advantage of being the development team
and the implementation team but if it
takes off Beyond us that is an issue
there'll probably be versions that have
to be updated every now and then and
distributed
and I'll just tag on to that also
um Heidi in that I think one of the big
potential benefits of having this type
of application is that you can try to
centralize
the the
um the knowledge expertise for some of
these clinical guidelines such that
people from all over are referencing the
same
Knowledge Center so that there's only
one place where hopefully you have to
update the guideline you know the the
guideline or the risk assessment rather
than everyone rolling out a new version
and then everyone across the country has
to like update their logic in their own
system
my question was sort of building on
Nicole's about maintenance so that's
maintenance about the clinical content
but what about the software itself like
what happens when there's a new epic
version that supports a different subset
of fire or ITV changes the security
policy and now whatever you were using
you can't use anymore
um how what's the experience been with
like the sort of practical
implementation part and how do you see
that expanding to other similar tools at
OHSU
it's a great question I think briefly
I'll just say
um fire has done some significant work
as a standard on the maturity level
management for the versioning and so
there are maturity levels including in
the last the most recent version they've
finally reached what they call a
normative maturity level for some of the
key resources and so
um to that extent if your phone if
you're if you're using the normative
resources you can have a good level of
confidence that they're not going to
have breaking changes for you as
versions upgrade however the you know
not certainly far from all the resources
are normative so it's an evolution I
think anyone who's using Innovative uh
software products like this has to be
ready to make updates to the software
fairly regularly and so it's a great
point that you know anytime you
implement something like this you have
to have an ongoing plan for how are you
going to support and fund the
development and maintenance of the
software and it's tough because a lot of
these types of applications don't have
um you know built-in Revenue generation
streams
yeah I know that's been an issue with
other decision-made things in the past
where the grant runs out and now there's
not money to
uh to manage it does it just you have
any institutional plan for how I imagine
these things could proliferate over time
and end up plugged into epic in all
kinds of ways does that would just as I
was just even having discussions sort of
administratively about how to how to
apply that sustainability there there is
there's a there's sort of a governance
task force for some of this stuff that's
in work final decisions haven't been
made but but actually interestingly
there's there's both the the
software itself and maintaining it and
and hosting it and that sort of thing
and then also epic of course in their
Infinite Wisdom charges money to use
these apis and so uh OHSU has been
working also to try to figure out how do
you fund how are we going to support the
actual kind of costs associated with the
licensing of the apis cost sharing
between applications Etc and so that's
all in ongoing discussions as we try to
manage this
and I can say when we for when we
started this work a few years ago
there's pretty there was pretty broad
interest in the tool I mean every group
that we presented to
both inside OHSU and outside OHSU was
really quite interested in one of the
tool
primarily for for the ability to better
identify patients at risk
so
um I think that
ultimately OHSU probably will need to
strategically think about
supporting tools like this
and I think those discussions have
already started
Nicole
sorry I have another question
um
so I was really interested in um
the results that you presented on the
differences between what the patients
self-reported and what was already in
the chart either in terms of data that
were not in the chart at all or that
actively disagreed
um
which is something that I'm very
interested in general
but I was wondering what kind of
response if there was any response from
the providers you heard what was their
reaction to data that disagreed with
what you know other people had already
put in the chart or something like that
foreign
the
first concern was oh my gosh this is
going to create a lot of messaging back
and forth
um
about what and especially if there's an
anxious patient who
um wants their record corrected
um immediately so we had so we include
included some um information on that
um the
what else did the clinician say let me
think
um I mean there are we
have
encouraged waiting till an appointment
and having it and having a discussion in
real time about it
as and putting a flag in for us to
remember in our sticky notes as the way
to manage it as opposed to getting into
back and forth my chart messages or
having a phone call so setting
expectations for how quickly it could be
adjusted depending obviously if someone
has a new high risk issue and wants to
get in
um
Etc that make that would happen more
quickly
um
we'll have to see as it happens more I
actually am as worried about the unsure
answers
um creating a lot creating on
um little
taking time to figure out with low
impact on change in care but
but that happens all the time in
practice right
or the patients aren't sure of the age
of their aunt who had
when they had breast cancer for example
there are also a few situations where
there's been discordant data where or
what seemed like discordant data when it
was really limitations on technology
like
like coding systems for example like we
don't have a really good specific coding
system that can say
history of chest radiation in in Epic
and so sometimes that can get a little
non-specific like if you have any kind
of history of radiation
it might pull you in and and suggest
that that's part of your medical history
even if it's not which then the patients
sort of say well I actually didn't and
you know so then it can be a little bit
of that kind of stuff that has led us to
do a little bit of debugging in our
application as well
so I would add that our clinicians have
experience with
um EHR data driving recommendations
through the HM functions specifically
for colon cancer and vaccinations Etc so
we're used to providing feedback when it
doesn't work quite well
um
or and seeking clarity
so it's not like something completely
new to us
thank you I want to be mindful of
everybody's time it looks like we're at
12 35. um the whole team is available to
answer questions feel free to email any
of us if you've got questions we're
happy to to to troubleshoot and respond
to your questions if you can think of
there's groups that you think this
presentation might be really helpful to
go forward with to help move things
along
that would be helpful too
thanks everybody
thank you
thanks bye-bye